aujourd'hui vendredi 19 décembre
bienvenue pour le journal de la
rédaction de tvfils 78 voici
quelques-uns des titres que nous allons
développer au cours de la prochaine
demi-heure plus que quelques jours avant
Noël et au pied des sapins certainement
des jeux édités parasmodés une société
fondée à la fin des années 80 par deux
yvelinois le siège se trouve d'ailleurs
toujours à Guyancourt retour sur une
successe story locale nous verrons aussi
comment les communes économistes sur
leur éclairage cette période de fête
avec notre invité Anna de la Forcade du
club Saint-Quentin association
chrétienne il sera question des crèches
que penser de la polémique sur leur
présence dans les halls des mairies le
club Saint-Quentin qui propose la
troisième édition de sa crèche vivante
et puisqu'il faut retenir de la semaine
entre le report du vote du budget 2015
de l'université et la gauche qui ne
parvient pas à réaliser l'union pour les
départementales
pour débuter ce journal nous allons
parler des décorations de Noël nos
maisons nos rues sont toutes décorées ce
qui peut faire monter nos factures
d'énergie pour y remédier de nombreuses
communes 5 continents ont décidé
d'acheter des décorations à base de LED
Mélanie pocket
on a beau les scruté quand on n'est pas
connaisseur difficile de faire la
différence entre les ampoules normales
et les LED et pourtant ces petits diodes
électroluminescentes sont bien là si
elles sont encore chères les LED
permettent d'éclairer jusqu'à 40 000
heures elle s'allume instantanément et
supportent les allumages répétés c'est
la technologie qui est bien meilleure
une lampe incandescence et un filament
qui chauffe c'est en gros 95% de perte
en chaleur 5% de rendement la LED c'est
optimiser pour éclairer c'est de la
microélectronique et c'est le rendement
de 95% avec très peu de pertes en
chaleur l'exemple d'une commune qui a
remplacé tout son parc et qui est passé
de 6000 kWh à 700 kWh soit des économies
de 88% si on fait le calcul les
consommations d'énergie
que les anciennes ampoules
Noël sans que la facture soit salée
trappe y consacre 15000 euros par an
on reste dans l'esprit de Noël avec un
succès 100% yvelinois 1986 de lycéens de
Viroflay décide de fonder leur société
pour diffuser leur propre jeu de rôle
près de 30 ans plus tard elle bénéficie
d'une renommée internationale son nom
Asmodée reportage dans leur locaux de
Florent parfait
des jeux de société à ne plus savoir
quoi en faire nous ne sommes pas dans
une future salle de l'atelier du Père
Noël mais au siège social d'Asmodée les
Aventuriers du Rail otarie show la
guerre des œufs bubble Jungle Speed ou
encore Elixir ils sont tous édités par
cette entreprise une PME et viennoise
devenue en quelques années le numéro 1
français des jeux de société elle
distribue dans les magasins spécialisés
les jeux qu'elle conçoit ainsi que ceux
de 36 éditeurs quand on rencontre des
auteurs ou des studios qui développent
des jeux où il y a juste une idée on va
les accompagner en fait pour développer
ce jeu et pour voir lancer le jeu sur le
marché et qu'on va retrouver le jeu dans
le dans les commerces donc on va tout
développer on va être en contact avec
les auteurs avec des designers des
graphistes le jeu de société dernier
rempart contre les écrans résiste aux
jeux vidéo et même à la crise la PME l'a
bien compris et elle ne s'adresse plus
seulement aux enfants la grosse tendance
ça reste bien évidemment les jeux qu'on
appelle partie Game c'est des jeux un
peu d'apéro qu'on joue entre adultes ces
jeux on se marre des jeux fun qui sont
rapides donc les meilleurs exemples
c'était Time's Up c'est Jungle Speed
c'est dobble c'est 700 000 exemplaires
vendus par an la meilleure vente de
l'entreprise née en 1995 dans les
Yvelines elle s'est d'abord installée à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux avant d'investir
ses locaux de Guyancourt au début ils
étaient vides aujourd'hui la société
emploie plus de 200 salariés chaque
année il lance près de 200 nouveautés
sur le marché du jeu de société un défi
de taille le secteur est soumis à de
nombreuses contraintes et à certains
plastiques qu'on appelle le PS qui
passent pas les normes
le PS passe certaines normes mais pas
toutes en fait ça dépend de sa
composition donc on est obligé de faire
des tests pour vérifier que ça passe
bien c'est ce qu'on demande à la base au
fournisseurs mais maintenant en fait on
vérifie systématiquement derrière que ça
passe bien les tests on nous dirige
aussi vers des matières plus écolos
maintenant des normes qui n'entravent
pas son développement à se moodet a
ouvert 8 filiales à travers le monde en
2013 l'entreprise est passée numéro 1
des jeux de société en France devant le
géant américain Hazebrouck un succès en
partie dû à son identité française
il y a une spécialité dans la création
française
on y a vraiment une french touch avec
beaucoup d'auteurs français qui ont un
style particulier un style de création
et de mécanique de jeu et il y a un
style d'édition française qui est très
léché avec beaucoup de qualité sur le
matériel la French Touch d'Asmodée
s'exporte dans près de 44 pays dont le
monde elle représente 34% des parts de
marché sur le segment du jeu pour la
période de janvier à mai 2014 mais
l'entreprise ne prend pas la grosse tête
et ne perd pas de vue son activité
essentielle il y a des gens qui jouent
leur plaisir souvent ils jouent le midi
ils prennent des sandwichs ils jouent
enfin il y a beaucoup de gens qui font
ça et après sinon il y a des séances de
jeu qui sont des vrais séances de test
où on joue au jeu pour le décortiquer ça
on fait ça plutôt le vendredi en
principe grâce à son nouvel actionnaire
l'Américain euraséo Asmodée a racheté le
groupe Days of Wonder et Fantasy Flight
Games l'entreprise estime à 200 millions
d'euros son chiffre d'affaires pour
cette année pour ses grands enfants la
partie est loin d'être finie
et à quelques jours de Noël vos cadeaux
sont-ils prêts c'est notre question du
jour oui mes cadeaux sont prêts presque
il me reste quelques-uns à faire bien
sûr oui tout à fait tout est acheté pour
les enfants les petits enfants vous êtes
plus en avance tout à fait pour éviter
toute la cohue de des magasins donc la
moitié c'est les magasins l'autre moitié
c'est par informatique Internet
pas tout à fait mais pas loin oui ils
sont tous achetés ouais si c'est la
question et il me reste plus qu'à en
emballer quelques-uns pratiquement
acheter certains et emballer d'autres la
moitié est prête oui mais c'est surtout
mon épouse qui s'en occupent moi c'est
des les femmes sont plus spécialisées
plus adaptées pour faire ses cadeaux aux
enfants aux petits-enfants à la famille
je chacun son métier je lui confie ça et
elle le fait très bien et puis toujours
autour de Noël sachez que des animations
seront proposés à Bois-d'Arcy samedi
matin demain face à l'Hôtel de Ville les
élus et les commerçants du marché
couverts annonce spectacle et je
conclure Noël c'est avant tout pour les
chrétiens la célébration de la naissance
de l'Enfant Jésus le club de
Saint-Quentin le club Saint-Quentin va
proposer dès samedi une crèche vivante
cortège et champ à partir de 15 heures
au départ de l'église
Saint-Pierre-du-Lac à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux bonjour Anna de
la Fourcade et bienvenue vous êtes
directrice de l'accueil de loisirs du
club Saint-Quentin le club Saint-Quentin
tout d'abord c'est quoi c'est une
association de loisirs éducatifs et
chrétienne
alors c'est une association oui de
loisirs tout à fait éducatif aussi avec
une qualité chrétienne aussi
effectivement
je précise simplement que le fait qu'on
soit chrétien ne veut pas dire que on
accueille que des chrétiens au contraire
c'est une association ouverte à tous
Voilà il y a pas de d'exclusion aucune
de cette association les activités vous
vous proposez le but vous le disiez
c'est pas de se rassembler uniquement
entre chrétiens
le but c'est vraiment d'être une
association qui va mener des actions au
service de l'éducation donc on a un peu
quatre branches pour ça la première qui
va être au service plutôt des enfants et
des jeunes où on va développer vraiment
le côté loisirs donc ça passe par un
centre de loisirs avec notamment un
accueil périscolaire etc qui a ouvert
cette année des semaines de vacances
organisées régulièrement depuis trois
ans
pour les enfants pour les adolescents
ça passe aussi par
des actions intergénérationnelles des
actions pour apprendre à se mettre au
service des autres notamment
et puis alors deuxième branche là on
arrive plus à quelque chose
d'événementiel donc il y a la crèche
vivante
on va parler il y a le rallye aussi de
la Toussaint troisième branche du club
Saint-Quentin qui tourne autour plutôt
des parents des propositions entre les
parents pour des l'éducation donc ce
sont des conférences qu'on leur propose
ouverte à tous autour de quel thème
alors récemment par exemple tout aime
autant d'éducation la prochaine par
exemple aura lieu sur l'orientation
scolaire comment aider les adolescents à
choisir
euh on a comment ça se passe une crèche
vivante qui participent alors en fait ça
commence à 15h les enfants sont attendus
à 15h il y a des enfants qui sont
déguisés désignés pour faire partie de
la crèche il représente Jésus non pas
Jésus qui est une poupée justement mais
Marie et Joseph
et puis les trois Rois Mages
et on va partir en défiler avec avec ces
fameux Rois Mages avec ces personnages
on va partir et puis on va aller et des
animaux aussi qui accompagnent
on va faire un petit chemin à travers la
ville et revenir à l'église où là il y
aura des chants de Noël un goûter offert
et puis des contes de Noël qui seront
racontés est-ce que ça dépasse le cadre
religieux on est plus dans la tradition
aussi là alors effectivement si on est
vraiment dans le côté
fêter Noël
devant cette crèche qui qui oui est un
fait partie de la religion chrétienne
mais qui est aussi dans la tradition qui
dépasse la religion bien sûr si je vous
pose cette question vous vous en doutez
c'est parce qu'il a cette polémique
actuellement autour de l'installation de
crèches qui ne sont pas vivantes cette
fois-ci mais tout de même dans des
mairies par exemple dans les lieux
publics où certains demandent à ce qu'il
n'y en est tout simplement pas est-ce
que vous comprenez cette position
une polémique autour de ça
parce que comme on vient de le dire ça
fait vraiment partie de la tradition
depuis
la naissance de Jésus de fait Noël c'est
la naissance de de Jésus et depuis 2000
ans on le fait
je regardais je me renseignais un petit
peu sur les crèches et je voyais qu'en
fait ça existe depuis le 13e siècle
quand même donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est qui est depuis des textes
de loi sur la laïcité sur la séparation
de l'état de l'église et pour autant les
crèches continuaient jusqu'à encore il y
a pas si longtemps être installé dans
les dans les mairies et ça ne crée pas
de polémiques est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans un climat un petit peu
différent et que c'est même il y a trop
de laïcité en fait il faudrait peut-être
un peu plus d'ajustements de souplesse
comment vous percevez les choses en tant
que en tant que chrétienne
c'est difficile d'être chrétien
aujourd'hui
difficile d'être chrétien je sais pas
trop de laïcité je sais pas par contre
effectivement
il y a des questions qui se posent là
aujourd'hui maintenant telles que cette
question de de d'accueillir des crèches
dans des lieux publics ou pas
qui se posait pas il y a quelques années
et il y a encore 5 ans enfin donc
c'est quelque chose dont vous parlez
entre vous justement
je comprends pas trop pourquoi tout d'un
coup
ça devient quelque chose qui va venir
agresser certaines personnes ou venir
offenser certaines personnes que de voir
des crèches parce qu'on est dans le
domaine de la tradition et que le pays
s'est construite cette manière là en
fait en quelque sorte ça fait partie de
la culture on va dire exactement
des des racines de enfin oui des
traditions de notre pays quoi pour en
revenir à votre actualité cette crèche
de Noël vivante il est possible de
rejoindre le cortège d'y participer même
si on n'était pas là pour la préparation
tout le monde est le bienvenu donc
samedi à ce rendez-vous prochaine action
prochain rendez-vous après est-ce qu'il
y a déjà d'autres choses de planifier
prochain rendez-vous écoutez non pour
les événements c'est un peu tout mais
après il y aura les conférences et puis
les accueils de loisirs qui sont
réguliers
Saint-Quentin point et faire l'adresse
qui s'affiche sur votre écran qui s'est
affiché merci d'être venu donc en
plateau crèche vivante 20 décembre
cortège et chant partir de 15 heures
départ église Saint-Pierre-du-Lac à
Montigny merci encore on passe à présent
à l'essentiel de la semaine comme chaque
vendredi
et dans l'actualité cette semaine du
nouveau en matière de transport les
usagers de la ligne u entre la verrière
et la défense vont voir l'offre
renforcée notamment les dimanches
Catherine zulato William elle
plus de train entre la verrière et la
défense actuellement le dimanche et les
périodes de fêtes entre la verrière et
la défense il n'y a qu'un train par
heure dorénavant à partir de 11h il y
aura un train toutes les demi-heures
comme sur les lignes C et N soit 19
trains supplémentaires par ailleurs en
semaine afin d'offrir une fréquence plus
régulière entre les lignes C N et U au
départ de 50 ans en Yvelines soit une
fréquence de 15 minutes deux trains
supplémentaires seront créés au départ
de la verrière à 15h35 et 23h50 ce lundi
en gare de La Verrière les usagers
étaient partagés sur ces annonces là ils
ont changé les horaires normalement
c'était à 11h05 et maintenant c'est à
11h20 mais ça aide pas de pas nous
prévenir ça suffit pas qu'il a plus de
train il suffit que il respecte les
horaires qu'il n'y a pas de problème
parce que c'est ça qui bloque
c'est que on sait jamais combien de
temps on va on va passer à attendre le
train et puis pour combien de temps il a
un livre arrivera à sa destination le
fait de rajouter des trains c'est
intéressant pour ceux qui travaillent le
plus qu'on va dire donc c'est bien de
qui est plus de ligne plus de plus
d'horaires en fait même même le weekend
parce que il y a beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent le week-end voilà c'est très
très bien parce que il y a des moments
qu'on a des trains qui sont souvent
supprimés c'est à plus de train c'est
vraiment formidable pour nous
le débat autour du budget à la région
vient de se terminer après trois jours
de discussion il s'est achevé donc ce
vendredi les socialistes à la tête de
l'institution souhaitent mettre en avant
les investissements notamment dans les
transports négociations autour de la
tarification unique du Pass Navigo
oblige le président Jean polluchon tient
aussi à mettre en avant les 425 millions
d'euros pour la construction et la
rénovation des lycées ou encore les 5
millions pour améliorer l'offre de soins
de son côté son opposant tu MP candidate
pour le succéder en décembre 2015 a déjà
déclaré qu'en cas de victoire aux
élections elle présenterait la facture
du Pass Navigo à tarif unique au Premier
ministre Manuel Valls interview donc de
Valérie Pécresse et de Jean-Paul Huchon
en replay sur notre site internet dès à
présent
autre budget débattu celui de
l'Université de Versailles 55 en
Yvelines 20 000 étudiants et seulement
23 ans l'an dernier confronté à la
logique implacable des dépenses en
hausse et des recettes à la baisse elle
établissement a été placée sous tutelle
de l'État sous perfusion le budget
proposé au vote ce mardi en conseil
d'administration était et cette fois-ci
à l'équilibre mais il a fallu pour se la
faire des économies les étudiants non
guère apprécié le reportage d'Anthony
Reich et de William hell
après un an d'austérité l'université de
Versailles 50 ans en Yvelines s'apprête
à voter un budget à l'équilibre pourtant
les stigmates de la rigueur sont encore
présents la filière STAPS a fermé plutôt
que prévu la fac de droit n'imprime plus
de polycopié les étudiants craignent à
terme la dévalorisation de leur diplôme
sur le marché du travail en sortant
d'université en déficit et en 2015 que
les taux ne se desserrent pas pour
donner un exemple le gvt le glissement
vieille technique donc ce qui fait que
les fonctionnaires plus travaillent des
années plus ont d'expérience plus
gainants salaires en fait l'état ne
s'engage à ne payer que 40% de ce de ce
glissement vieille technique du coup
c'est aux universités sur leur fonds
propres de devoir assumer les 60% du
coup pour avoir un budget à l'équilibre
ils sont obligés de couper dans les
autres budgets dont la formation par
exemple en 2015 il y aura moins de place
pour les étudiants dans les formations
en Licence ou en Master et c'est pas
nous payer les pots cassés pour
protester contre ce vote de budget
prévisionnel cette vingtaine d'étudiants
s'apprêtent à entrer deux forces dans la
salle de réunion du conseil
d'administration
après une quinzaine de minutes passées
dans la salle de réunion les étudiants
ressortent du bâtiment de l'université
avec le sentiment de la mission
accomplie mais ce serait heurté au refus
de dialogue de la direction on est
rentré à l'intérieur de ce conseil
administration et tout de suite le
président de l'université à tout de
suite hurlé il y avait des membres du
conseil d'administration qui hurlaient
des membres élus quand même des gens qui
sont censés garder leur canne pour
pouvoir discuter posément on n'est pas
rentré on est rentré ici de manière un
petit peu rude mais à l'intérieur c'est
juste posé autour faut juste pouvoir
discuter on avait tous préparé des
choses à dire pour pouvoir en débattre
avec eux exprimer les craintes des
étudiants n'ont même pas voulu les
entendre ils ont préféré annuler la
séance pour nous faire passer pour des
gens violents la démarche de ces
étudiants s'inscrit dans un mouvement
national contre la baisse de dotation de
l'État pour l'enseignement supérieur le
vote du budget 2015 de l'université et
donc repoussé à une date ultérieure pas
encore connue
Najat Vallaud-Belkacem éducation
toujours avec la ministre donc qui a
dévoilé ce mercredi les collèges qui
obtiennent le statut de rept pour réseau
d'éducation prioritaire cette
appellation remplace les anciennes zèpes
les zones d'éducation prioritaire à
Saint-Quentin trois collèges sont
concernés Gustave Courbet le village et
yuri Gagarine situé donc à Trappes on va
écouter Bertrand mesure à présent le
secrétaire départemental snuippf et 78
il regrette qu'une telle mesure ne
concerne pas la globalité du cursus
scolaire d'un élève écouté
on part des réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire donc des écoles élémentaires
maternelles qui alimentent ces réseaux
or on se retrouve en particulier dans
les Yvelines avec un certain nombre
d'écoles qui se retrouvent isolés parce
que pour leur malheur elles alimentent
un collège ou existent une vraie mixité
sociale pour autant la situation de ces
écoles quand elle est prise
du point de vue de la situation de
l'école est une situation
particulièrement dégradée je vais en
donner un exemple c'est celui du bois de
l'étang à La Verrière qu'on ne peut pas
qualifier de situation favorables et qui
pour autant va sortir l'éducation
prioritaire au motif que les élèves de
bois de l'étang vont à Philippe de
champagne au Mesnil-Saint-Denis
des pépites on lit pas assez c'est tout
le monde noir c'est tout mais faut
montrer qu'on a des résultats et c'est
vrai dans les évinnes il y en a j'ai
oublié de dire que dans les années où
j'étais là on a vu progresser les
résultats des élèves de façon étonnante
alors évidemment on voit l'excellence
sur les territoires ou les familles sont
plus favorisés de manière très très
forte avec des mentions encore plus
grandes dans les années passées mais sur
les terrains territoires plus
défavorisés je vous donne un exemple
parmi d'autres on a on a doublé le taux
d'accès au baccalauréat dans les
quartiers des favorisés en bref il faut
à mon avis faire essayer d'être influent
ramener tout le temps tout le monde à
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est qu'on est
là pour les autres on est là pour les
enfants et que globalement ça doit se
faire avec une confiance dans l'avenir
et puis beaucoup de modestie d'humour de
distance
interview complètement Catherine sulato
a retrouvé dès lundi dans le journal
élections les départementales c'est pour
le mois de mars prochain 22 29 mars il
s'agira de lire ce qui siègeront au
Conseil Général nouvelles législation
oblige le nombre de cantons a été réduit
passant de 39 à 21 mais les Conseillers
généraux élus le son maintenant en
binôme Paris terre homme femme après
l'UMPC autour du Parti socialiste de
présenter ces candidats mais au congood
ce week-end le binôme en lice pour le
canton de Maurepas était dévoilé il n'y
aura pas d'union de la gauche dès le
premier tour vainqueur en 2008 à la
faveur d'une triangulaire avec deux
candidats de droite Ismaïla Vannes se
représente pour un nouveau mandat et
avec lui Marie-Christine merci premier
adjointe de Mani les hameau elle aussi
socialiste pas d'alliance à gauche donc
et pour Europe Écologie Les Verts la
stratégie éclaire se démarquer au
maximum de la politique menée par le
gouvernement écoutait le responsable
départemental d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts c'était sur ce plateau mercredi
soir
nous on a envie de construire et c'est
pour ça qu'on a lancé il y a 15 jours un
appel au rassemblement donc un large
appel sur nos valeurs pour essayer de
fédérer ça peut être des collectifs ça
peut être des citoyens ça peut être
aussi des mouvements politiques pas des
socialistes en tout cas mais
repentir
ce qu'il veut mais l'idée c'est quand
même d'avoir un message clair autour de
nos valeurs donc nécessairement le
message c'est pas nous sommes contre
quelque chose le message c'est de dire
on peut faire autre chose dans les
Yvelines la droite dans les Yvelines
fait depuis des années une politique
très libérale avec un peu de saupoudrage
de social par-ci par là et c'est contre
cette politique qu'on voudrait vraiment
inscrire les Yvelines dans dans les
Yvelines du 21e siècle quelque chose qui
soit beaucoup plus soutenable en termes
de développement économique et donc on a
un programme alternatif à proposer à
construire avec ce rassemblement qu'on
veut qu'on veut créer et sur notre site
internet l'intégralité de cet échange à
retrouver grâce au Replay et si vous
voulez pouvoir voter en mars prochain
que vous venez de déménager il faudra
vous inscrire sur les listes électorales
vous n'avez que jusqu'au 31 décembre de
cette année donc pour le faire après il
sera trop tard explication dans ce
service de l'état civil à Guyancourt
Catherine zulato Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude
service état civil de la mairie de
Guyancourt depuis le début de l'année le
service enregistré deux sans
inscriptions supplémentaires sur les
listes électorales la commune compte à
ce jour 17 870 inscrits et depuis
quelques jours c'est un peu plus
l'influence l'inscription sur les listes
électorales se fait du 1er janvier au 31
décembre et on clôt les listes
électorales au 31 décembre de l'année en
cours et passer cette date n'est plus
possible de s'inscrire tous les nouveaux
arrivants dans les communes tous les
gens qui ont déménagé au sein de la même
commune et tous les gens qui arrivent
enfin qui déménagent dans une autre
commune doivent absolument signaler leur
changement d'adresse
sur place vous devez fournir un
justificatif de domicile et une pièce
d'identité c'est une procédure que
chacun peut également faire sur Internet
la mairie de Guyancourt ouvre aussi une
permanence le mercredi 17 décembre à la
Maison de Quartier Auguste Renoir les
données sont ensuite entrées dans un
logiciel de traitement des listes
électorales les cartes d'électeurs
seront imprimées au mois de février pour
être transmise au titulaire avant le
premier tour des élections
départementales prévues le 22 mars après
le 31 décembre il n'est donc plus
possible de s'inscrire sauf qu'à très
particulier il y a quelques cas
dérogatoires mais faut être militaire
éventuellement si on a si on était muté
puis qu'on revient en France on peut
s'inscrire mais c'est vraiment très très
peu de calme et naturalisé les
naturalisés français qui sont
naturalisés avant l'élection et ensuite
les jeunes qui auront 18 ans la veille
de l'élection
une commission de révision des listes
électorales composées des lecteurs
notamment et chargés de valider toutes
les inscriptions ainsi que les
radiations cette commission se réunira
le 10 janvier le 28 février et 5 jours
avant le début de l'élection deux
échéances électorales sont prévus en
2015 les élections départementales donc
fin mars et les élections régionales en
décembre
tout de suite sur TV file le 7 8
weekends vos loisirs pour les prochains
jours la semaine prochaine pour le
journal Catherine zulato je vous
retrouve néanmoins mardi pour un 7-8
politique autour notamment de Philippe
Chevrier le responsable départemental du
Front National et d'Aurore berger UMP
membres du collectif une droite d'avance
bon weekend